[Applause]
thousands in the rain crying out for
federal intervention to overturn the
results of Brazil's presidential
elections
supporters of Brazil's president James
bolsonaro marching towards military
headquarters in Rio de Janeiro they
don't accept bolsonaro's defeat and want
the Armed Forces to intervene
[Music]
we want the military to annul the
elections Lula de Silva shouldn't have
been allowed to run for president who is
imprisoned on corruption charges and
only participated in the race because
the Supreme Court overturned his
conviction
the protesters also believe bolsonaro's
unfounded allegations that the election
was rigged
[Music]
until they get what they want which is
basically a federal intervention to
prevent president-elect Louisiana
from taking office on January the 1st
crowds banged on the doors of military
Barracks across the country and in
Brazil's largest city Sao Paulo
meanwhile police and riot gear are
trying to clear roadblocks set up by
truck drivers who also support bolsonaro
but they're still disrupting traffic in
at least 14 Brazilian States
tensions grew after a car rammed into a
blockade injuring seven people including
two Federal Highway policemen
bolsonaro who was being criticized for
keeping silent made a public appeal for
peace
these protests are a legitimate let's
not lose the legitimacy of the Pacific
protests happening all over the country
the three-month transition from
bolsonaro's government to Lula da silvas
will officially start on Thursday but
many here say it will be far from Easy
Monica yanake valjazeera Rio de Janeiro